la correction dans le marché immobilier
et plus rapides et plus profondes que
prévu après avoir atteint un sommet en
février le prix des propriétés a
commencé à diminuer rapidement et c'est
loin d'être terminé desjardins s'attend
à ce que le prix moyen au canada chute
de 23% du 6 décembre 2000 23 par rapport
aux sommets les baisses les plus fortes
devraient avoir lieu dans les provinces
où les prix ont le plus grimpé dans les
dernières années pour le québec
desjardins prévoit une baisse de 10 7%
du prix moyen en ontario la baisse
devrait être autour de 24% et en
colombie-britannique recul prévu et 2
22% malgré ces chutes le prix des
propriétés devrait rester au dessus des
niveaux d'avant la pandémie dans toutes
les provinces
hélène bégin économiste principale chez
desjardins est avec nous ce soir pour
parler de cette étude bonsoir madame
bégin
bonsoir alors qu'est ce qui explique la
baisse de vos prévisions est ce que
c'est la hausse des taux d'intérêt est
ce que d'autres facteurs derrière cette
révision
en fait il ya plusieurs ya plusieurs
raisons à ça de ne pas comme vous l'avez
mentionné les prix ont ont dîné à
beaucoup plus rapidement qu'on l'avait
anticipé notamment en ontario et en
colombie britannique
ensuite la hausse des taux hypothécaires
a été très rapide beaucoup plus
prononcée et ce n'est pas terminé
d'ailleurs donc ça fait en sorte que les
coûts des mensualités pour les nouveaux
acheteurs beaucoup augmenté et l'autre
élément c'est que le marché et
fascination d'où il y avait une pénurie
très important à une situation
pratiquement les marchés équilibré
presque partout au canada donc trois
éléments qui font en sorte que les
présidents qu'on avait mis un flingue
d'une bonne base qui paraissait
audacieux déjà en juin mais l'algérie
sur l'afrique oui effectivement mais le
marché marque changer de cap très
rapidement et faut penser aussi que les
prix au canada et c'est déjà d'environ
15 pour ça donc d'avoir une diminution
de tours d'entre 20 et 25 je pense que
c'est le scénario le plus probable
surtout que ça va se poursuivre au cours
des prochains mois on voyait tout à
l'heure au québec le sommet a été
atteint un peu plus tard je crois et
leurs kühl est un petit peu moins
prononcée que pour l'ensemble du canada
ce sera différent estime
respectivement au québec on avait quand
même un momentum du côté du marché
immobilier on s'attendait à ce que les
prix diminuent avec un certain décalage
par rapport aux fesses du canada si ce
qui s'est produit cependant on a atteint
un sommet en avril on est déjà quelques
mois de buzz et jusqu'à maintenant les
prix ont reculé d'environ 2% québec dans
ses possibilités
cependant comme ailleurs au pays les
conditions de marché ont changé
rapidement des revenus comme j'ai
mentionné un marché plus équilibré et le
fait aussi que il ya eu quand même
beaucoup de surenchères dans certaines
régions québec sont pense l'est de
montréal et les jambes wesley
l'outaouais l'estrie donc les régions eu
beaucoup de surenchères ça vaut dans le
fond ça commence à s'atténuer et ça va
s'amplifier dans les prochains mois de
sorte que la base prévu qui est très
limité jusqu'à maintenant vont quand
même atteint 2,17 pour ça si la fin de
l'an prochain est-ce qu'on est rendu
dans un marché d'acheteurs où on est
juste entre les deux parce que ça a été
longtemps un marché favorable aux
vendeurs est ce qu'on est rendu dans un
marché favorable aux acheteurs
maintenant
pas encore globalement ça c'est certain
que cela peut varier d'une localité
alors est ce qu'on observe pour
l'instant c'est qu'évidemment les
vendeurs ont perdu leur avantage leur
pouvoir de négociation justin qui
permettait de faire monter les enchères
donc on semaines de marche un peu plus
équilibré et la première reste en fuite
leurs marchés qui se voulait en surplus
au marché
ça va mener au cours des prochains mois
on a vu que la situation a changé
rapidement les taux d'intérêt continuent
de monter
l'économie commence à montrer certains
signes d'essoufflement donc évidemment
arrivé dans un marché qui est un peu
plus à l'avantagé des acheteurs ça va
venir au cours des prochains mois qu'est
ce que devraient faire les gens la
maison qui envisagent d'acheter une
propriété
prochainement est-ce qu'on attend est ce
qu'on achète maintenant quand même
qu'est ce que vous en pensez
mais ce n'est pas la situation c'est
certain que dans un contexte houleux
les surenchères ce sont beaucoup de ce
prix va se permettre d'acheter une
propriété présentement à prix qui est un
peu plus réaliste un peu plus près de la
valeur la valeur marchande
habituel donc ce aussi bien du côté des
vendeurs mais évidemment ce qui était
resté sur les lignes de côté pendant la
pandémie par exemple les personnes d'un
certain âge vont peut-être porté à
procéder rapidement pour éviter dans ce
fonds d'avoir avant au moment où les
prix va voir diminuer ceci dit faut
garder en tête que malgré la diminution
la moyenne des prix aux restait quand
même
plus élevé qu'avant la pandémie donc
c'est quand même c'est quand même c'est
quand même bonne humeur c'est ça on
parle d'à peu près 20% je crois dans
votre rapport par rapport à février 2020
à la fin ou 2023 est ce que ce sera la
juste valeur du marché est ce qu'on
aurait effacé toute la surchauffe à ce
que ce sera vraiment le bon prix pour le
marché immobilier à ce moment là
oui je pense qu'on va y arriver
globalement la tout dépendant évidemment
de là de l'endroit que l'on se trouve
mais on va arriver à déléguer prick sont
beaucoup plus près de la réalité avec
les surenchères qui vont disparaître
graduellement donc c'est certain que
c'est intéressant avec buzz le primat
même temps lorsqu'on regarde l'ensemble
de l'abordabilité donc la capacité
financière des ménages à acquérir une
propriété
il faut à la fois tenir compte des
primes également des taux d'intérêt non
ici à court terme même si à court terme
les prix continuent de baisser les taux
d'intérêt ont eu mon art sens inverse
non ça fait en sorte que les mentalités
sont plus élevés donc que plusieurs
acheteurs qui aimeraient acheter ni
charisme pourrait se qualifier ou encore
qui arrive avec un autant d'emprunt qui
permit qui est moins élevé qu'il ne
l'était lorsque les taux d'intérêt
étaient beaucoup plus bas en début
d'année donc on aimerait ça ça sera pas
simple c'est ce que je comprends
exactement merci beaucoup d'avoir été
avec nous madame bégin aujourd'hui très
éclairant tout ça merci ça me plaisait
au revoir pour voir nos émissions en
entier rendez vous sur la chaîne ici et
redit